Oh
right now the agriculture that we depend
on in this country is is very heavily
fossil fuel-based soil is a kind of
matrix for holding plants upright so you
can pour oil over them to make them grow
the average bite of food you eat has
traveled 2,000 miles to reach your lips
it's marinated in crude oil by the time
it gets there the incredibly intense
energy use of agriculture is an
astonishing problem it generates lots
and lots and lots of our greenhouse
gases and it depends on supply of
petroleum that's quickly running short
so we need something different and the
outlines of that something different or
pretty clear I think we need to replace
some of that fossil fuel with human
labour and energy on farms at the moment
one percent of Americans farm there's
half as many farmers as prisoners in
this country we're never going to go
back to fifty percent of Americans on
the farm but we're going to have to head
a little bit in that direction because
we need more hands at work growing our
food and substituting for some of that
endless fossil fuel and it turns out
there's lots of people who want to do
that kind of work and as we see demand
grow farmers markets have been the
fastest growing source of fastest
growing part of the food economy for ten
years now as we see that growth taking
place we get more and more and more
farmers coming forward to meet it which
is very very nice to see it'll help
immensely if we put a price on carbon at
the Congressional level at the global
level the day that that happens the
logic of the farmers market will be
immediately apparent not just two people
who want good food but two people who
understand what an insane subsidy we've
been giving in a form of cheap fossil
fuel to big industrial agriculture
the the gap between rich and poor in
this world has always been a sin but now
it's a wicked practical impediment to
getting done that which we need to do um
if you live in China where there's still
600 million people living in pretty
bitter rural poverty the world looks a
lot different to you than if you live in
a American suburb the easiest way to
pull those Chinese or rural Indians or
Africans or South Americans out of that
poverty would be to burn the cheap coal
that's widely available in most of those
places that's how we did it in this
country over the last 200 years that's
what fueled our prosperity it's a cruel
thing to say to people in those parts of
the world look you can't do this because
the atmosphere is already filled by us
so in moral terms and in practical terms
we have very strong incentive to not
only cut our own emissions to give other
people some room but also to transfer
some wealth in the form of Technology
mostly north to south to allow those
societies to skip over as much of the
fossil fuel stage as they can and go
straight into the kind of world of
renewable power that's only just and
it's only smart